this is supposed to be a debate based on
fact and truth and the truth and the
fact is
joe biden has been very clear he will
not raise taxes on anybody who makes
less than four hundred thousand
a year appeal the trump tax cuts mr vice
president i'm speaking
i'm speaking be important if you said
the truth vice president mike pence and
democratic vice presidential nominee
senator kamala harris just finished
their one and only debate in this
election season
three important things worth saying
about this debate first of all they
managed to have a more serious
substantive and civilized conversation
than their bosses president trump and
democratic nominee
joe biden did last week senator i want
to thank you and joe biden for your
expressions
genuine concern second i think both vice
president pence and senator harris
managed to accomplish their main task in
this debate which was to look like
plausible presidents
in case circumstances require that and
that's really important in a campaign in
which the two nominees
are a 77 year old man in the case of joe
biden and in the case of president trump
a 74-year-old man who recently
contracted coronavirus
these two people needed to look like
plausible presidents and i think they
cleared that bar
but third i think this will be
remembered above all as the coronavirus
debate
the american people have witnessed what
is
the greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
democrats and senator harris view the
administration's handling of the
coronavirus is kind of a metaphor for
the entire trump presidency
and here are the facts 210 000 dead
people in our country
in just the last several months over 7
million people who have contracted this
disease
for his part vice president pence
started with the defense that the
president took the most important and
the toughest step
president donald trump did what no other
american president had ever done
and that was he suspended all travel
from china the second largest economy in
the world
vice president pence argued that the
plan that biden harris ticket puts
forward to combat the coronavirus if
they win the election
looks an awful lot like what the trump
administration is already doing
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
you know one reason that the democrats
like to bring up the coronavirus
is they also use it as a way to enter a
conversation about the broader subject
of health care
that the trump administration wants to
eliminate obamacare during the
pandemic if you have a pre-existing
condition
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
they're coming for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you
coming for you if you are under the age
of 26 on your parents coverage
they're coming for you and one other
subject of note that's going to be
remembered from this debate
is the supreme court are you and joe
biden going to pack the court
vice president pence like president
trump last week
managed to point out that the democratic
ticket does not want to say whether or
not it supports a plan
to expand the size of the supreme court
and change the ideological makeup of the
court
re-elect president donald trump will
stand by that separation powers in a
nine-seat supreme court
let's talk about pac in the court then
this is an idea that is pushed by
progressives in the democratic party and
the biden harris ticket does not want to
offend them by opposing it but it also
doesn't want to support it publicly
because that
scares some centrist democrats and
independent voters so it's avoided
taking a position
something vice president pence brought
out during the debate
and something you'll be hearing more
about in the weeks to come